Tên Rồi Tên, 2 mệt tăng tham một đưa tên. Truyên tham Trung Quốc của tụi Tung Anh Kieu
giảm ơn giữ xa Trung Quốc cành chất tự của tế, còn giống hiệu phần hoa,
thuốc giữ quan tâm của giới qua xa Cút Tế. Lấy là chuyên tham đầu tiên của
một tụi tưởng tương Anh từ bắc kinh kể từ năm 2018, được có là bất đi nhằm
thu dài đối thoại và tăng cường hợp táu trất giữa Hà Vềm. Thôi các phần tích
Cút Tế, chúng khi chính xác nước Mỹ trên hết của Mỹ, thì thực tạo ra những điều
tình lớn cho quan hệ với các nước, Trung Quốc đã tăng cường tiếp sức bà làm ấm quan hệ
bởi nhiều nền tình tế quan trọng. Bắc kinh nhìn mạnh phai chào là đối tăng thu mại
ở định. Thông đại hợp táu cung có lợi vào ủng hộ thương mại tự gió.
Bây giờ anh chính phố của tụi tưởng xa mơ khả lệnh theo đua kế tế cận thức dụi
giới chỉ quan hệ xam sông với Mỹ, lên mình cho ông về Trung Quốc,
đơn đường trường xang về bất kinh là cân thiết. Nhà mỏ chợ phù bôi tăng trường
bầu tí trối của mình. Giờ qua sân nhận định tự kết trường thông dần đây,
của lãnh đạo cân nước anh, phần lãnh và cân nader, có thể thấy Trung Quốc đang chủ đậm
cùng có vị thay kinh tế và chính trị cho bất cảnh cục sản thần cầu tiếp tục biến đậm.